hey everyone who remembers that happy
time in their career in their life even
when you were just starting out as a
software developer so many big ambitions
of building exciting products learning
lots of cool new technologies doesn't
last long does it you end up working on
projects where you're creating crazy
estimates and building the CTA's pet
project which never gets delivered but
actually for me when I look back whoops
when I look back I don't quite have
those happy memories I look back and I'm
kind of it's a bit awkward because I was
a massive expert beginner like after
just one or two years I thought I had
everything figured out I thought I had
all the answers and I'd be with senior
engineers they'd be talking about
distributed systems continuous delivery
always interesting stuff I'd be having
my suggestions yeah we should use WCF
and Silverlight into the future now it
wasn't that I was arrogant it's just
that I wanted to feel important I saw
them doing all of this big interesting
architecture stuff and I wanted to get
involved and I just found it really
frustrating they were doing all the
interesting architecture stuff and I was
fixing their CSS bugs not quite where I
wanted to be but one day I noticed
something that would change my career
instantly I walked past the bookshelf
and I saw this book and I knew right
there this book is going to change my
career I'm gonna read this book and
overnight and then become a senior
developer and this book was called
professional Business Objects Wow
I want to be professional I want to do
business he stuff on ER they all this
fancy object stuff in my code and I was
just thinking to myself how fantastic
this moment was and how this book would
change me and a senior developer came
over and he said to me no no no don't
make that book it's yeah it's not for
you oh my gosh they
book is so good he doesn't want me to
read it because he knows if I read this
book he's gonna be fixing my CSS bugs
but then he says to me read this book
instead domain-driven design and I was
like what I don't know anything about
design I'm terrible at design and he
says no no no it's it's about software
design just give it a try if you read
this book ten years from now you'll be
glad you did okay I'll give it a try I
don't know about ten years from now ten
minutes from now I'm reading this book
and I'm thinking what have they done to
me all I'm seeing his tons and tons and
tons of verbose Java and um now I what
kind of joke is this
so here's my question is it possible
that ten years later I could have
learned something from this book and
actually that seemed developer was right
is it possible that the young me the
expert beginner was wrong about
something so actually I there is and
that's why I'm here today I'd like to
talk to you about some things I've
learned from this book but I don't want
to talk about my journey and get excited
about this book what I want to talk to
you today is about today is I think
there are some insight in this book that
are more useful now this book the manger
in design I think now some insight in
this book which are more useful now than
they were when the book came out fifteen
years ago how can this be possible
well let's just take a look at a few of
the current trends we're seeing in tech
so firstly we've got serverless
anyone using serverless you will be soon
so service has come along and the cloud
providers AWS Amazon same thing as your
they're taking away the stuff we care
about they're managing the
infrastructure and so as developers the
things we care about
moving high up the stack for most of us
I know some people like playing with
kubernetes clusters hopefully it's just
the fad but the future is less
infrastructure more focusing on the
business stuff that's that's where the
industry is going and when we think
about this when we look at trends in
product management what product managers
have found is the best source of ideas
actually comes from talking to customers
but in a very close second place
it's the developers the best way to
build great products is to let the
developers and the whole team who are
building the product have ideas about
the products they're building and so
what we're seeing now in the top
companies the leading companies is a
process called continuous and discovery
and delivery we have this one team
cross-functional team developers testers
designers everyone we need in a team and
the whole team is doing discovery
they're going out there talking to users
they're doing user research and the team
including the developers the whole team
is choosing what should we work on what
features should we add to our product
and then they decide to deliver the
features they think are most useful I
don't really have time to talk about
this today but here's some excellent
books like highly recommend on this
topic one other thing I'd like to talk
about is the kind of systems we're
building so if we look at the general
trend we're going from bigger monolithic
systems to small microservices systems
so there are more pieces in the
architecture but what we're also seeing
is that the shape and the type of those
pieces is different it's not just closed
on a server now it's all kinds of
devices the last project I worked on we
installed thousands of devices on the
streets of New York
this one I'm working on now I'm working
with a company called Navajo and we're
building smart boats devices installed
on but hundreds and thousands of boats
all pinging data back to the server
he's very different for me from the
systems like worked on and this is a
trend we're going to see continue and be
that the kinds of system they'll all be
working on smart fridges smart lights
more everything so based on these trends
that I'm showing you here
I honestly think there was some insight
in this book which you'll find really
useful I'd like to talk to you about
them today and I'd like to start with
something called exploration
what's that goal of software developers
when we're creating software it's about
two things in my opinion firstly it's
about sustainability being able to
continuously improve the software we're
building no point building a piece of
software hitting a deadline and you
can't improve it in the future
so actually creating great code is about
being able to sustain and evolve a
codebase over time but the problem is
that's not an easy thing to achieve and
I've seen things like this before
and this is a true story worked at a
company the codebase was so bad they
couldn't keep up with the innovation of
their competitors and that the code the
code was throwing away the product was
cancelled and how those people were
fired don't touch on that too much it's
not a great moment in my life but it's
it's a truth so how do we create
evolvable systems solid principles
that's white solid code testing let's
test our code modularity let's make our
code modular and loosely coupled these
things will make our code sustainable
and evolvable well maybe they won't
actually because if you want to create
sustainable and evolvable code it needs
to be as simple as possible I think we
can all agree that the simple something
is the easier is the change but if you
want to create simple code you need to
represent in a business problem you're
solving in the simplest possible way and
if you don't understand the business
problem well enough you can't represent
it in your code as simply as possible so
we need to understand the domain what we
learned from this book is the first
model we create is always very naive and
superficial and I've
a counter this many times and actually
when we think about the factoring we're
factoring isn't just about cleaning up
the code it's about reducing the
complexity of our code by making it much
more closely with the business domains
we're representing in the code now
here's the problem the main German
design talks about all of these things
about understanding your business you
use it to solve problems in code
but it doesn't really give you any
techniques for actually working with the
business which I kind of find a bit
frustrating in a way like you're giving
us this book about understanding the
business and you're not giving us really
any techniques for actually working with
the business to understand the domain I
don't consider you about a valid
solution we can talk about that later I
did try it a few times trying to do this
UML stuff with business people that
didn't work out for me didn't try that
again meetings you know general purpose
meetings getting around a whiteboard it
can work a little bit but it's not the
best not the best format for sharing
knowledge when you're trying to get into
a domain so we have this problem in DDD
for a very long time for 10 years we
have this problem where we're talking
about let's understand the business
problem and yet we have no techniques or
really understanding the business and
then this guy turns up alberto
Brandolini and he starts talking about
this crazy thing called event storming
event storming is this crazy idea that
we get developers business experts
domain experts we get them all together
and we model the business on a wall
together so that everyone has a shared
model of the system of the domain and
they can have conversations about the
domain this is how developers can learn
about the business and the the thing
about event storming is it's just so
incredibly simple it's like what we'll
be doing for 10 years you get an orange
post-it and you taking
event from your business so if you're
building a software system for a
conference you might have call for
papers opened and then you model each
event in your business process as a
timeline it's pretty simple if it's a
long time to work this out but think
about this right
developers can do this the main experts
can do this it's a very simple model of
your business
anyone can join in and we can all
discover this domain together and share
knowledge it's really simple and really
powerful and it really does work but you
don't stop with offense events is just
the starting point you can add commands
and users and business policies and
external systems and any kind of
information you want
so now as developers we don't really
have an excuse for not understanding the
business problem domain working in
because we have a technique like
advanced storming which helps us helps
us understand the business reduce the
complexity in our code and I just like
to share with you a few of my personal
clients with event storming so as a fan
of domain driven design I've always had
this desire to get my whole team
passionate about the business that's
very easy with event storming you get
everyone in a room with the business
experts with your post-its everyone can
get involved and start understanding the
business it's very powerful in that way
think about how you've modeled domains
before I'm guessing normally it's around
a whiteboard how much information can
you fit on a whiteboard not a lot with a
van storming you can model a whole
domain on an entire wall like this and
have the whole thing mapped out and you
can start seeing how different parts of
the process I'll link together insights
you just wouldn't get with another
technique and you can actually get
domain experts engaged with you for a
long time maybe some hours when I talked
about meetings before meetings with the
main experts typically don't last that
long it just gets very boring very
quickly
and personally I feel like when I do
events for me I really get into the
domains I'm working and I start asking
lots of questions about how the business
works how it should work I feel like I'm
really engaged on it on a personal level
too so I don't actually want to tell you
that you should all go and learn event
storming I actually want to make you
think a bit more wider than this so
there's this quote in the book I mean
Eric has this quote in the book but he
didn't give us techniques but he's he's
telling us he's saying you should really
embrace the domain you're working in use
it in language and every way possible
and I think what he was trying to say is
that we need to find better techniques
from understanding the domains are
working as technical people developers
it's on us to find ways to understand
the business domain better and so
Alberto says event stalling is his pizza
you can put your own topping on there
and it's true it's exactly what I'm
saying it's go find out some better
techniques don't stop here let's keep
looking for better techniques we love
making frameworks let's start finding
better techniques for understanding the
business problem we're working in he's
got a book out called a van storming
which you might want to check out but
trying to quickly talk about a few other
people so Kenny Kenny bass he's I'm
sorry Stefan Stefan Hoffer he's working
on a technique called domain
storytelling Kenny he's been combining
event storming an example mapping and
Sofia she's been working on the concept
of a domain quiz where you write a quiz
about your domain and challenge your
developers to see how much they know now
it's not a punishment it's a way to
understand what they know and where they
gaps are and help them to improve
although it could be a punishment if you
want to I don't like punishment by the
way well sometimes I do okay let's talk
about something else before I embarrass
myself completely let's talk about
design
so we're software people we love our
rules our laws and that principles it
was always a correct way to do something
as a junior developer I was told you
should write dry code Nick
do not repeat yourself ever okay I'm
gonna never repeat myself I'm never
going to like the same bit of code twice
a few months later Nick your code is
terrible too many abstractions what is
it is this thing a rule of law what what
you trying to tell me am I supposed to
do this dry thing or not
next one Nick your classes are too big
you should follow the solid principles
all your classes should have a single
responsibility few months later Nick
your code is terrible too many
abstractions yagna one day a senior told
me is like oh yeah gimme what kind of
insults that he's like you ain't gonna
need it you're writing some code that
you don't need yet there's no
requirement to solve yet you're adding a
feature that's not needed your code is
too complex okay just a few weeks later
I'm working with that same developer I'm
like hey yogini you're adding a HTTP
endpoint and we don't need it yet he's
like oh oh no I'm allowed to do this
because if we don't build this HTTP
endpoint now we won't have time to when
the business ask for it later so now is
the last responsible moment so in
software we have a lot of people who
like to think in terms of these rules
and laws and principles you should
always follow but actually there are no
rules or laws or principles should
always follow what you find when you
talk to ddd people is they're very
passionate about these things called
heuristics so it's not a rule it's not a
law it's a principle it's kind of a clue
maybe it will work and maybe it won't
just just try it out and see where it
gets you think for yourself and so again
in in the book Eric talked about this
idea of good modelers good designers
they're good at taking lots of
information they good at exploring lots
of different ways of modeling a system
not following a simple rule or law but
exploring different ideas and thinking
for themselves
it took me it took me a long time to
really grasp this concept but now I
think I can explain it really well
you see software designed like a
supermarket who's ever been to a
supermarket and not being able to find
something because it wasn't where you
thought it was so I recently had this
problem actually it was a Sunday lunch
time I had lunch with my wife and I said
oh I fancy a dessert and viennetta would
be amazing
not had a viennetta for like ten years
who knows you know viennetta right the
ice cream cake thing and she said why
don't you get some squirty cream and
chocolate sauce
squirty cream and chocolate sauce on
viennetta let's do this I went down to
the supermarket I was convinced this
would be the best dessert I've ever had
and I started looking for the chocolate
sauce so I just walk over to the dessert
section all kinds of desserts and
toppings and extras and stars and all
this kind of stuff but actually no
chocolate sauce here by wise then and
chocolate sauce by the dessert section
chocolate sauce is a dessert or it's
used with desserts where could it be
chocolate okay chocolate chocolate sauce
is a chocolate so I head over to the
chocolate section and see my Belgian
chocolate Swiss chocolate all kinds of
fancy chocolate but no chocolate sauce
so okay kind of worried they don't have
any now maybe it's not the right season
for chocolate sauce maybe their specific
season when you can buy chocolate sauce
maybe I'm like let's let's keep this
keep this thing going sorry
chocolates oh it's a sauce white
chocolate sauce so I kind of convinced
myself it could be a sauce I think I
walked over to the source section with a
lot of doubt in my mind I started
looking at my ketchup mayonnaise Levi
Roots Reggae Reggae sauce but I'm not
seeing any chocolate sauce here and now
I'm starting to worry might flee places
it could have been and it's not in any
of them so I look for someone who's
working there and I it takes me a while
and I see this guy he's like super busy
and he's like stacked up with pizzas and
pork pies and Scotch eggs and he's like
he's really doesn't want me to speak to
him
we need to find these chocolate sauce
tonight hey where can I find the
chocolate sauce and he says to me it's
down by the freezers by the by the ice
creams but chocolate sauce isn't
something you freeze it all that's down
there like 7-foot fries as it can't
possibly be down there so I'm kind of
annoyed I think he's lying to me anyway
I start walking over there and I'm in I
mean like the middle lane
you know how the supermarket had like
blocks I'm like in the middle lane with
the aisles on each side I walk right
down to the end might take a laugh into
the ice-cream and I just see big
freezers but right down at the end I see
something like what's that thing over
there it looks like an abandoned lunch
trolley and I'm walking and I get closer
I mean I'm like oh my gosh it's shampoo
and chocolate sauce on an abandoned
lunch trolley in the ice-cream section
and so I was telling my friends about
this Mike this is just like software and
they told me to call it the chocolate
sauce heuristic so let's let's just take
a step back for a moment how could this
be about software so think about what we
do in software it's about taking these
different bits of functionality and it's
about grouping them which things belong
in a class which things belong in a
micro service so if we look at these
concepts here how would we group these
well we could group them by shape or we
could group them by color or we could
group them by unique combinations and
this is just like software things can be
combined in different ways because they
share different characteristics with
different concepts
just like the supermarket and the
chocolate sauce which I think should
live with the sauces but let's get back
to software and it's like a real example
now so here's the company who built a
financial products marketplace using
their products you can buy credit card
deals mortgage deals or loan deals how
do we design this system
well it's quite easy right there credit
cards context the mortgages contacts and
the loans
contacts but actually what they found
was inside each one of those contexts
there was the same pattern emerging we
have deals for people with a low credit
rating poor deals high interest rates
some body ethics going on now I don't
want to talk about but then some better
deals people with a great credit rating
and a higher score so now there are two
ways we could design this system by not
stopping at the first obvious model now
we've seen two ways two different
characteristics for organizing this
system and so the point I'm making is
when you're designing code or
architecture look for heuristics try and
use heuristics that challenge your
assumptions and make you look at the
system in a different way because there
are always different ways of modeling
your system and until you've looked at
the system from multiple perspectives
you can't have any confidence you've got
the best solution and so that's my
hidden lesson that's my hidden lesson
I've worked with people who take this
Huestis based approach they're not
telling me
dry solid they're telling me think about
your system from this perspective
why don't you group them from this
perspective and I think that's something
we should all be striving towards the
domain driven design book itself
contains a lot of heuristics about
language look for concepts with the same
name look for two different things with
a different name which are really the
same thing and there are plenty of
design heuristics out there I'll talk to
you from a few of my favorite so the
money heuristic find parts of your
system which are worth the most and
organize them together to marry me
heuristic walk with time supports so the
Mavi needs us think is not one of mine
but it's basically someone said if
you've got two parts of your code or
your architecture and they're and
they're really coupled and they're
talking to each other a lot maybe they
should get married and it's just one
concept
well the Valentine here is thick I was
working with a massive supermarket in
the UK and they talked about how they
redesign their complete architecture and
their teams thousands of people all
right
how could you possibly get this design
right how can you be confident he's got
a good design here how do you know if
you've put things in the right places
and they said well for a lot of it it
was quite obvious but I'm like yeah
there are always edge cases where you
put one thing in the wrong place and you
have lots of dependencies and they said
well we played this game and we asked
ourselves which team or which part of
the system would love this feature the
most who's gonna take that feature and
develop it to its full potential who
loves it the most that's another
heuristic and also about aligning things
with the source of change thinking back
to the finance example we have different
customers who want our system for change
in different ways
maybe instead of organizing by products
we organize by the people the different
people who are asking our system to
change in different ways I've also got
another us they called the game of
phones us Nick and I think I'm running
out of time so I'll leave that one to
your imagination but if you are
interested in more heuristics again
Kenny Kenny's working on the site called
DDD heuristics everything van Cal is
always interested in talking about
social qs6
and Hien is always talking about
decision making u.s. dick so lots of
people are talking about heuristics and
if you really want to improve as a
designer and an architect I think us fix
on the next good place that go on we've
got some great people in the industry to
learn from here some great mentors but
just one final note so I was talking to
Matias not too long ago and I said do
you ever get this thing where you you
just suggest to your client a very
simple idea have you tried this and
they're like oh my god you're a genius
consultant and he said yeah that happens
a lot he said but I'm not a genius
consultant I just have better heuristics
and that's a quote I live by they don't
need to be the smartest person I just
need to have the best us dicks so I
asked the best questions and I see the
best possible solutions that other
people don't anyway let's talk about
business because heuristics won't get
you all the way to your solution
so hew s --tx challenge you to look at a
problem in different ways but they don't
really tell you how do you choose the
best one what's the best what's the best
alternative way to design software or
architecture in this particular
situation and it depends but what does
it depend on so domain driven design
gives us this concept of distillation
where we have core supporting and
generic subdomains and the idea is you
look for your core domains you look for
the parts of your system which have the
highest value and you align your
architecture so that you can exploit
those core domains best so if we go back
to the financial product example which
was the best solution there by the
products or by the customer ninety five
percent of your revenue comes from
credit card deals may be organized by
credit cards and focus on that the most
maybe that's your core domain but if
your business has ninety five percent of
revenue coming from people with low
credit rating and I don't like you if
you're one of those companies but if
that's your business model then maybe
you should focus on aligning with that
characteristic instead so you need to
understand your business model you want
to be a good architect or a software
developer you need to understand the
business model in fact how can you
actually say to yourself or your
colleagues or your team or your boss how
can you say we've designed this new
system and it's the best possible
architecture for and needs if you don't
understand the business model I just
don't know how that's possible I just
think you have to understand the
business model and also another another
relating thing I found is we often think
of coupling and in software as a very
technical thing we look at different
parts of the code and see those things
which belong together but actually what
you find is when you understand the
business the things that change in your
code together will depend on which parts
of the business are changing the tickets
and the initiatives you have in your
roadmap will influence which parts of
your system will be coupled working on
those features anyway one final thing
I'd like to talk to you about and it's
not brexit it's organization I would
like to talk about brexit but not for
very good reasons so organization a few
years ago I worked in the UK government
you take government being a big agile
digital transformation all that kind of
stuff you might have heard of GDS
government digital service and basically
I was working in a team I was working
three teams and they were working really
well for government teams it was amazing
we were doing continuous discovery and
delivery we were going out the whole
team was talking to our users citizens
of the UK and optimizing our system
based on what they were asking for and
then one time the users were telling us
you've just launched a new service we
can't even use it like my address is
five lines long and your address fields
are three lines long now this is a big
deal because it was a service for
helping you calculate your business
taxes your business property taxes if
you can't enter your business property
address you can't really do much when
you're stuck back on the old paper-based
forms that's no problem
where the software developers will fix
it so we went to make this three lines
text field five lines but we had a
dependency on a back-end team who had a
dependency on a database team and a week
later I'm sitting in a meeting with five
project managers so you put a text box
on a web page I'm a little frustrated
and it didn't work out
couldn't we couldn't do it teams are too
busy they've got six months release
cycles getting all of these teams to
whatever is impossible so that was a bit
of a no I'm not a great moment in my
career actually I was quite maybe not
quite like this but I was quite sad but
after this it motivated me to try even
harder so I started talking to senior
in the government agency right look we
have all of these problems we can never
release simple things like adding a text
box we need to work more effectively we
need to change our system so that teams
can implement very simple features very
easily now I listen to me no one
listened to me and I was upset and had
some more moments and then out of the
blue one day I received an email and it
said there's going to be a meeting next
week about those topics you've been
talking about oh okay
maybe they will finally listen to me
after all so I get to the meeting CTOs
there are lots of big people there and
the ctsas programmers are too slow there
were liability we've just bought a rules
engine and a BPM system so we don't need
programmers okay not the result I was
looking for in that situation I must
admit I wasn't feeling too happy that
day but let's get this back on track
what was the problem here the problem
was we had a software architecture that
looks like this we needed five teams to
put a text box on a webpage once they
introduced their new BPM a rule system
now we needed six teams to put a text
box on a webpage that's the that's the
kind of pain I went through but my point
is we often talk about micro services
having these lots of small pieces but
we're just making our architecture more
complicated sometimes it's not about the
size or the number of those pieces that
matters and you often hear people
talking about micro services should be
bounded contexts they're kind of the
same people who were creating these big
complicated architectures and if you
look in a domain driven design book if
you look the answers without 15 years
ago but if you've read that section on
bounded context in the domain driven
design book it's all about teams
it's about creating loosely coupled
systems which enable teams to work
independently and make changes quickly
and if you look there were all kinds of
quotes the shape of the architecture
must be reconciled with the shape of the
organization it's all about the problem
to merge when the weight when teams
aren't organized the right way all about
teams so the lesson here is that when
we're designing software systems we
really have to think as much if not more
about the teams who will be building and
maintaining those systems and that's
what bounded contexts are they were
socio technical construct but don't take
my word for it Nicole for screwin Jess
humble Jean Kim they've been doing the
DevOps surveys for the past four or five
years they've surveyed thousands of
companies and guess what they found the
biggest predictor of continuous delivery
performance was a loosely coupled
software architecture and an
organizational structure to match the
biggest predictor was getting your
architecture and your team design right
but don't take that word for it
thought works did their studies - and
what they found is the shape of the
teams matters a huge deal when a piece
of work leads the team when multiple
teams must collaborate on a single piece
of work it takes an order of magnitude
longer to complete that piece of work
and if you're having lots of small
microservices and lots of small teams
just think about that what are you
actually doing here you get your
boundaries wrong so the hidden lesson is
is quite clearly that software
architecture isn't really a thing it's
so so technical architecture thinking
about technical boundaries and team
boundaries collectively as one thing so
I'm almost done now it's gonna recap on
what we talked about during this talk so
firstly I think the first takeaway is be
passionate about your domain but
let's try and find better ways of
understanding the business domains were
working in techniques like event
storming and domain storytelling let's
get excited about these techniques as
much as we get excited about frameworks
for example secondly we are building
systems which are complex in different
ways more pieces different types of
pieces different kinds of devices on
boats and fridges and all these kind of
things simple rules and rules don't work
here dry yagna these aren't things we
can just follow simply solid we can't
follow them simply we need heuristics
that help us to think about how can I
look at this problem in a different way
and create different solutions to this
problem and then if we want to start
answering those questions like which is
the best solution here you need to
understand the business model really if
you don't understand your business model
how do you know you've got the best
architecture to solve business problems
and finally it's all about being
socio-technical if we start making our
software architectures more complex we
can make it even harder for the teams
building those systems to get work done
so let's just think about that so my
summary is that based on the trends
we're seeing and the ones I talked about
earlier I think that software developers
in the future or I'm convinced software
developers in the future will be more
product and business focused and there
will be social technical thinkers
thinking about the shape of their teams
and their software and providing more
focus there but that's just my thing my
thinking of how things could go it's
really up to you about where you want to
take things maybe you think I'm wrong so
I'm currently working at Nava Co if
you're looking for a job we're hiring
apart from that I'm finished thank you
very much
[Applause]